MUSIC Sean, you'll never guess what we're gonna do today. Are we gonna record an episode? Did I just guess it right? Uh, well, first, man, how many times, baby steps? First thing we're gonna do is we're gonna welcome our audience and we're gonna say... Oh, welcome to... Welcome to...
MUSIC Sean，你绝对猜不到我们今天要做什么。我们要录制一期节目吗？我猜对了吗？呃，好吧，首先，老兄，多少次了，循序渐进？我们要做的第一件事是欢迎我们的观众，我们要说……哦，欢迎来到……欢迎来到……
Smartness. I try to do it in time. Okay, sorry, one more time. One, two, three, one, two, three. No, the moment's gone. Oh. Welcome to Smurlus. Smartness. Smartness.
机智。我尽量卡在点上。好吧，抱歉，再来一次。一，二，三，一，二，三。不，时机已经过了。哦。欢迎来到 Smurlus。机智。机智。
Smartness. Smartness. Speaking of hydrating, did you run six miles yet today, Bevan? No, no. It'll be after this. I didn't think so. Just looking at you, I didn't think so. I'm holding a little water right now, yeah. It's gonna be after this session. So I got real tight, I got a hard out in 55 minutes.
机智。机智。说到补水，Bevan，你今天跑了六英里了吗？没有，没有。录完这个再去。我就知道。看你这样子，我就知道。我手上现在还拿着点水，对。这期录完就去。所以我时间很紧，55分钟后我得准时走。
I was boxing today. I did my... You know, I'm doing this thing, boxing at home. I mean, I know, listen, it's a tough guy thing, obviously. You box at home, like in your garage? Yeah, like just with boxes. Like I'm just putting boxes together. Oh, okay. Beautiful. What did you think I meant?
我今天去打拳击了。我做了我的……你知道，我在搞这个，在家打拳击。我的意思是，我懂，听着，这当然是个硬汉的活儿。你在家里打拳击，就像在车库里那样？对，就跟纸箱打。我就把纸箱堆在一起。哦，好吧。太棒了。你以为我指的是什么？
Do you don't really have... You're not one of those dorks with a heavy bag. A heavy bag hanging in your garage. Ew, that's gross. Do you really have one? It's not hanging. It's on a stand. I got one of these things. It's on the ground. He just tackles it.
你其实没有……你才不是那种会在车库里挂个重沙袋的白痴。车库里挂个重沙袋。呃，真恶心。你真的有一个吗？没挂着。在支架上。我买了个这种东西。在地上。他直接扑上去。
Thoreau talked me into it. And then you look at Thoreau's arms. He's on the cover of Esquire, Justin Thoreau. Thank you. Jesus, why haven't we had Justin on the show yet? Because we want to talk about him more. We haven't talked about him enough on the show to then have him on.
Thoreau说服我的。然后你看看Thoreau的胳膊。他上了《君子》杂志的封面，Justin Thoreau。谢谢。天哪，为什么我们到现在还没请Justin上节目？因为我们想多聊聊他。我们在节目里关于他的话题还不够多，所以还不能请他来。
I would like... I met him like once or twice, such a nice guy, but I don't know him like you guys do. I would love to have him. Well, Will, which one of us... They can't really be surprised. One of us has got to... Well, one of us is going to get on it
我很想……我大概见过他一两次，人特别好，但我没你们那么了解他。我超想请他来。好吧，Will，我们俩究竟……他们其实不会太惊讶。我们俩总得有个……好吧，我们俩中得有一个去联系他，
and the other one's going to be surprised that the other one did it first. Look, anyway, we got to get to our guest. Our guest is an incredible writer, performer. Started as a performer, became a writer, then started becoming a performer again. And the second I mentioned one of the things you're going to be like, I know exactly who this is.
然后另一个就会对对方抢先一步感到惊讶。听着，不管怎样，我们得聊聊我们的嘉宾了。我们的嘉宾是一位不可思议的作家、表演者。从表演者起步，后来成了作家，接着又开始当回表演者。只要我提到其中的某个特点，你就会说，我完全知道这是谁。
We've talked a lot over the episodes with people who've been on SNL. We haven't had anybody who's been on the anchor desk. This person was on the anchor desk for many years. Tina, Tina, Tina, Tina, Tina, Tina. She wrote mean girls. She wrote everything. She did everything.
我们在节目里和许多上过周六夜现场（SNL）的人聊过很多。但我们还没请过任何一位坐过主播台的人。这位曾经坐镇主播台多年。蒂娜，蒂娜，蒂娜，蒂娜，蒂娜，蒂娜。她写了《贱女孩》。她什么都写。她什么都做。
It's Tina. Tina. Hi, my three buddies. How are you? Oh, look at her. He's outside. You can't say anything and then not know that it's Tina. Thank you.
是蒂娜。蒂娜。嗨，我的三个好哥们。你们好吗？哦，看她。他在外面。你不能什么都不说，然后还装不知道这就是蒂娜。谢谢。
Hi. Wait, are you in... Is that an outside area of your apartment that I never saw the outside area? No, I have a weekend home now, since the last I saw you, Sean. There's no apartments in the Hudson Valley. No, she weekends in the Hudson Valley.
嗨。等等，你在……那是你公寓的室外区域吗？我从来没见过那里的室外区域。不，我有个度假屋，自从上次见你之后，肖恩。哈德逊河谷可没有公寓。不，她在哈德逊河谷过周末。
This is her weekend home. It's my weekend home. Tina, do you and I have the exact same frames? I think yours look black and white. Mine look a little tortoisey. And can I say something? Just so you know something what I'm dealing with here, there's an incredibly passive aggressive nine-year-old
这是她的度假屋。这是我的度假屋。蒂娜，你和我的眼镜框是不是一模一样？我觉得你的看起来是黑白的。我的看起来有点像玳瑁纹。我能说句话吗？为了让你们知道我在这里面对的是什么，这里有一个极其被动攻击的九岁小孩，
out here with me who will not vacate the area. Really? And she's playing some basketball, which is like, this is probably the first day in her life that she's chosen to play some basketball, and it's during this podcast. But that's okay. It's a great ambient sound.
跟我待在外面，死都不肯离开这个区域。真的吗？她还在打篮球，这大概是她这辈子头一天选择打篮球，而且偏偏挑在这个播客录制的时候。不过没关系。这是很好的环境音。
Incoming, incoming. It's great ambient sound. So Tina, tell me, so yes, we've all been at home for the last year or some version of home or in one of our many homes. In one of our many, many homes. So relatable. But do you, so what does that mean
有球飞过来了，飞过来了。这是很好的环境音。所以蒂娜，告诉我，是的，我们过去这一年都待在家里，或者某种形式的家里，或者在我们多处住宅中的某一个。在我们众多、多处的住宅中。太有共鸣了。但是你，这对于现在的你意味着什么，
for you right now, getting back to it? Because you're always, I always feel like you're always creating, I know you've just created a new show. Yeah. Right, that's about to start. Yeah, well, I just, we have a, I produced a show called Girls Five Ever
重新开始？因为你总是，我总觉得你一直在创作，我知道你刚创作了一个新节目。对。对吧，马上就要播出了。对，好吧，我刚，我们有个，我制作了一个节目叫《Girls Five Ever》，
that comes out on Peacock on May 6th. Wait, what's it called? It's called Girls Five Ever. And it's a comedy, it's super funny. It starts you out with a laugh, there we go. Yeah, Girls Five Ever. I love the title. It's about a bunch of women who were in sort of
将于5月6日在 Peacock 上线。等等，叫什么？叫《Girls Five Ever》。这是一部喜剧，超级搞笑。一开始就能逗笑你，就是这样。对，《Girls Five Ever》。我喜欢这个名字。讲的是一群女人，她们大约在2000年时曾属于
a Danity Kane level girl group around 2000. And then their song gets sampled now. And they're like, should we, we're all 40. We should get our band back together, right? And it starts, it's- That's a good idea. It's really funny. Yeah, it's really funny.
一个类似于 Danity Kane 级别的女子组合。然后她们的歌现在被采样了。她们就想，我们要不要，我们都40岁了。我们是不是该让乐队重组，对吧？故事就这样开始了——是个好主意。真的很好笑。对，真的很好笑。
It's Meredith Cardino's the creator on it. And it stars Sarah Bareilles who is a delight. And her voice is ridiculous. And she's incredible. And also she's like a lovely natural actress. And then Renee Elise Goldsberry who you know from, oh, I don't know, fucking Hamilton? Will, Jesus.
Meredith Cardino是这个节目的创作者。主演是Sarah Bareilles，她太讨人喜欢了。她的嗓音简直离谱。她太不可思议了。而且她还是个可爱自然的演员。还有 Renee Elise Goldsberry，你从，哦，我不知道，他妈的《汉密尔顿》里知道她？Will，天哪。
You get the look off your face. Are you saying that? You're saying that? Cause I'm the only, for so long, I was the only person who hadn't seen it. And it was my badge of honor. Cause I was like, I don't want to see a fucking musical. Stop telling me it's so great.
你收起那种表情。你在说这个？你这么说？因为我是唯一一个，很久以来，我是唯一一个没看过这剧的人。这是我的荣誉勋章。因为我想，我才不想看什么狗屁音乐剧。别再跟我说它有多棒了。
It's a musical. And did you? I get it. I did see it, it was great. Yeah, it was great. Yeah, it was great. And I was wrong. And then wait, let me tell you the other two ladies.
这就是个音乐剧。然后你看了吗？我懂。我看了，确实很棒。对，确实很棒。对，确实很棒。我之前错了。然后等等，让我告诉你另外两位女士。
Busy Phillips. Sure. And American treasure, Paula Pell. Oh, she's the best. Oh my God, Paula Pell. We were just talking about Paula Pell. So Paula Pell was a writer on center night live forever. And now, and not now, but always kind of an actress now,
Busy Phillips。当然。还有美国之宝，Paula Pell。哦，她最棒了。天哪，Paula Pell。我们刚刚还在聊 Paula Pell。Paula Pell 曾在《周六夜现场》当了永远的编剧。现在，也不是现在，但一直都算是个演员，
but people are finally recognized her. So that's great that you're clear. Well, she sort of, you know, we always joke with Paula that she finally aged into her type cause she was always the kid at like 12 years old. She was in the play with gray spray in her hair. And now she's like, she's her actual type now. Gray spray acting.
不过人们终于开始认可她了。所以你能说清楚真的很棒。嗯，她某种程度上，你知道的，我们总是跟 Paula 开玩笑说她终于老得符合她的戏路了，因为她以前总是扮演12岁的小孩。她在戏剧里头发上喷着灰色发胶。而现在，她终于演符合自己实际年龄的角色了。灰色发胶演技。
Yeah, columnist, she's reeked of gray spray for 30 years in her life. Sure. So Tina, we have to do this because, but for you, it's, you know, obviously you hate going back over like, oh, this is what I did. But it's interesting to everybody who listens. And it's super interesting to us because,
对，专栏作家，她的人生有30年都散发着灰色发胶的气味。当然。所以蒂娜，我们必须聊聊这个，但是对你来说，显然你讨厌回顾过去，比如，哦，这就是我做过的事。但这对于每个听众来说都很有趣。这对我们来说也超级有趣，
not to embarrass you, but you're such a fucking huge piece of the comedy landscape and have been for so long. And you're such a great voice, incredible writer, incredible performer. You started, yeah, I've just always, you know, there's a butt, hang on Tina. No, there's no butt.
不是想让你尴尬，但你在喜剧界真的是个他妈的巨头，而且已经很久了。你有着如此美妙的声音，不可思议的作家，不可思议的表演者。你开始，是的，我一直都觉得，你知道的，有个转折，等等，蒂娜。不，没有什么转折。
I'm always very fond of you. And I'm such a huge fan in awe of your talent. You started in, you moved to Chicago in early 90s. I, let me think, yeah, 90, I graduated in 92, spring of 92, I graduated from the University of Virginia. So I think I moved in the fall of 1992. Yes. So you're from Pennsylvania and then you moved,
我一直非常喜欢你。我是你的超级粉丝，对你的才华充满敬意。你开始于，你是在90年代初搬到芝加哥的。我，让我想想，是的，90年，我92年毕业，92年春天，我从弗吉尼亚大学毕业。所以我想我是在1992年秋天搬过去的。是的。所以你是宾夕法尼亚人，然后你搬到了，
I know, so you moved to Chicago, you start second city, right? Yeah. So I went to UVA kind of randomly and then I went to Chicago and I started Improv Olympic first and class at the second city. And that's where I met Amy Poehler. Sure.
我知道，所以你搬到了芝加哥，你加入了第二城剧团（Second City），对吧？对。所以我有点阴差阳错地去了弗吉尼亚大学，然后我去了芝加哥，我先加入了 Improv Olympic，然后上了第二城剧团的课程。在那里我遇到了 Amy Poehler。当然。
And a bunch of other people that only Amy Poehler and I know, but like, but like Kevin Dorr from Brian Stack and Miriam Tolan, all those guys, Dratch, Rachel Dratch. Yeah, Dratch. Those were your contemporaries. I remember like those were, that was kind of your crew, all those people.
还有一堆只有 Amy Poehler 和我知道的人，比如像 Kevin Dorr、Brian Stack 还有 Miriam Tolan，所有这些家伙，还有 Dratch，Rachel Dratch。对，Dratch。那些都是你同时代的同行。我记得就像那些，那就是你的核心圈子，所有这些人。
So is it crazy that like three of those people end up on Saturday Night Live? I mean, that's, that's like the odds of that is crazy. I mean, it isn't, it isn't, I guess because well then at the time there's like the groundlings, standups, the groundlings and second city were the places they looked. Now, you know, the internet has become the great equalizer
所以，其中三个人最终进入了《周六夜现场》，这不是很疯狂吗？我的意思是，那，这种几率太疯狂了。我的意思是，也不是，我想是因为当时有 Groundlings剧团，单口喜剧演员，Groundlings 和第二城剧团是他们寻觅人才的地方。现在，你知道的，互联网成了伟大的平衡器，
and find people on YouTube. You find people on TikTok, presumably. I'm so surprised they didn't run into you. Yeah, you were a musical director. Well, you didn't run into me because I don't think, cause you were a musical director out in the Burbs, right? Yeah, in the Burbs, but I was always downtown Chicago, always around the, I had some friends at second city.
你可以在 YouTube 上发现人才。大概你也能在 TikTok 上发现人才。我很惊讶他们竟然没撞见你。对，你当时是个音乐总监。好吧，你们没撞见我，因为我不觉得，因为你当时是郊区的音乐总监，对吧？对，在郊区，但我一直在芝加哥市中心，总是在那附近，我在第二城有些朋友。
I'm just surprised we never. And the bus station. The bus station. Wait, so Tina, so you, that, those are kind of your peeps. I know that like Dratch and Amy and, and Stack and Miriam and all those kinds of guys were your. Yeah, and Horatio. Yeah, yeah.
我很惊讶我们从未遇到过。还有汽车站。汽车站。等等，所以蒂娜，所以你，那些，那些算是你的核心死党。我知道 Dratch、Amy、Stack、Miriam 和所有这些家伙都是你的。对，还有 Horatio。对，对。
We got another one on SNL. Glazer, like all those kinds of people were there too, right? Like in Chicago. Glazer, I was Glazer's understudy. I was John Glazer's understudy. Yeah, and then he left to do Dana Carvey, right? Yes. To work with Dana Carvey.
我们在 SNL 又遇到了一个。Glazer，所有这些类型的人当时也在那儿，对吧？就像在芝加哥。Glazer，我是 Glazer 的替补。我是 John Glazer 的替补。对，然后他离开去参加 Dana Carvey 节目了，对吧？是的。去和 Dana Carvey 合作。
And I got to go on to the main stage when he left, yeah. So then you moved from Chicago to SNL, like McKay and those guys were kind of seniors when you guys were freshmen. Is that kind of the idea? Adam McKay. Exactly. Adam McKay was already head writer at SNL
他离开后，我得以登上主舞台，是的。然后你从芝加哥搬到了 SNL，麦凯（McKay）他们算是你们这群新人的学长。大概是这种概念吗？亚当·麦凯。没错。亚当·麦凯当时已经是 SNL 的首席编剧，
and he, I submitted my writer's packet to him because I had been on stage at Second City and Lauren Michaels and Marcy Klein had come to scout talent and zero interest in me as a performer. So I was like, well, writer's packet it is. And then. And just for people who don't know, Adam McKay was Will Ferrell's business partner
我把我的编剧作品包提交给了他，因为我曾在第二城剧团的舞台上演出过，洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）和玛西·克莱恩（Marcy Klein）曾来看过人才，但对我作为表演者完全没有兴趣。所以我当时就想，好吧，那就靠编剧作品包吧。然后。
and writer of SNL and writer of all these amazing movies. And then he directs crazy, huge movies now. And yeah. Now he directs a lot of like dramatic movies. He's an Oscar winner now, guys. Yeah, yeah. But also for Wisconsin, there is a, you can either be a performer or a writer on Saturday Night Live.
为了让那些不知道的人了解一下，亚当·麦凯是威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）的商业伙伴，也是 SNL 的编剧，以及所有这些精彩电影的编剧。然后他现在执导疯狂的、巨作级别的电影。对。现在他执导很多剧情片。他现在可是奥斯卡得主了，伙计们。对，对。
And sometimes you make the leap. You get hired as a writer like Sudeikis. I remember Sudeikis this first year was a writer. Yeah, Sudeikis was a writer, did not want to be a writer. Conan was a writer. The best part about Sudeikis being a writer and not wanting to be a writer was that he let everybody know. So in the best way, in the best way.
不过，对于威斯康星人来说，在《周六夜现场》，你要么是表演者，要么是编剧。有时你会实现跨越。你作为编剧被雇佣，比如苏戴奇斯（Sudeikis）。我记得苏戴奇斯第一年就是个编剧。对，苏戴奇斯是个编剧，但不想当编剧。柯南（Conan）以前也是编剧。苏戴奇斯身为编剧却不想当编剧，最棒的一点在于他让所有人知道了。以最好的方式，以最棒的方式。
Sina, did you, were you one of those people that always dreamed of being on a Saturday Night Live? Because I hear so many alum saying, oh, when I was a kid, all they ever wanted. And then they get their, and then their dream comes true and they're on Saturday Night Live. Yeah, it is.
蒂娜，你，你是不是那种从小就梦想加入《周六夜现场》的人？因为我听到太多从那毕业的人说，哦，当我还是个孩子的时候，他们梦寐以求的就是这个。然后他们实现了，然后他们的梦想成真了，他们加入了《周六夜现场》。是的，确实如此。
I feel like I still wanted to be on Saturday Night Live. That to me, I would like, it would be hard for me to understand meeting anyone who didn't want to do that. Right, right, yeah. What do you mean you don't want to do that? And then were you disappointed that they didn't, that they didn't select you for the performing part
我觉得我依然想加入《周六夜现场》。对我来说，要我去理解怎么会有人不想做那个，这对我来说很难。对，对， yeah。你这话什么意思，你怎么会不想做那个？然后，当他们没有选你进行表演部分时，你有没有感到失望，
or were you more comfortable writing anyway? I was always a bit more of a writer even the way I contributed to the company. In Second City, I definitely was like an idea person. I wasn't someone, I didn't have that magic thing that Horatio Sands or Rachel Dratch have where like they come out and you're just like, oh, this is gonna be good.
还是说你本来就觉得当编剧更自在？我一直稍微更偏向于编剧一点，甚至从我对团队的贡献方式来看也是如此。在第二城剧团，我绝对是个出点子的人。我不是那种人，我没有 Horatio Sands 或 Rachel Dratch 那种神奇的特质，就是他们一上台，你就会觉得，哦，这肯定很精彩。
Like they just sparkly, you know. But don't you feel like to a certain extent, like you're kind of, I don't know, this is gonna sound mean for performers, but you're kind of over qualified to be a performer. Like it's really hard to be a writer, I think. Really hard to be a director. Less hard to be an actor
就像他们浑身带光一样，你知道的。但是你不觉得在某种程度上，就像你有点，我不知道，这听起来对表演者可能有点刻薄，但你当表演者有点太大材小用了。我觉得当编剧真的很难。当导演真的很难。当演员没那么难，
because everybody does that every day anyway, whether you're an actor or not. I mean, people change their behavior when they're with their grandmother versus their best friend. Like people know how to adjust the way in which they come across, like that's acting. But writing, I feel like that's really difficult stuff.
因为不管你是不是演员，每个人每天都在做这件事。我是说，人们和奶奶在一起时表现出的行为和跟最好朋友在一起时是不一样的。人们知道如何调整自己给人的印象，这就是表演。但写作，我觉得那是极其困难的事情。
Yeah, I mean, I think it's more work, the writing and directing. It is like people who are really good actors. Listen, acting is like 99% having a good face. It doesn't have to be a beautiful face, it's like an interesting face. It could be, you know what I mean? It could be Lupita Nyong'o, it could be Steve Buscemi,
对，我的意思是，写作和导演需要更多的工作。这就像那些真正优秀的演员。听着，演技大概有99%取决于拥有一张上镜的脸。不一定非得是美丽的脸，得是一张有趣的脸。可以是，你知道我的意思吗？可以是 Lupita Nyong'o，可以是 Steve Buscemi，
but you gotta have a face that people wanna look at. And that's like 99% of it. And then the other, like then 0.4% beyond that is talent. But I think you have that. I think, you know what you were saying about Horacio and Rachel, you have that thing too, where you come out and people are like, oh my God, that's gonna be so good.
但你必须得有一张人们愿意看的脸。那占了大约99%。然后剩下的大概0.4%才是才华。但我认为你拥有这个。我觉得，你刚才说关于 Horacio 和 Rachel 的那些，你也有那种特质，你一出场，人们就会觉得，哦天哪，这肯定太棒了。
Because it's you, it's Tina Fey. It was always fucking funny and always delivers. So I think people get adjusted as excited. That's very kind of, I think now, I think I've like slowly worn people down. I think it's been like, it's mirrored my dating life in every way. I'm just like, I'll wear you down.
因为那是你，是蒂娜·菲。总是他妈的好笑，而且总能带来精彩表现。所以我认为人们一看到你就兴奋不已。你太客气了，我想现在，我想我慢慢把大家给“磨”习惯了。我觉得这在各方面都映照了我的约会生活。我就是那种，我会把你磨到心服口服的类型。
But Tina, you gotta admit, like in the best way, like you kind of trojan horse them, like, you know, Marcy and Lauren come in and they sort of like, okay, and they don't even see you or whatever. And then you come and you submit your packet. Obviously, McKay wants, you know, he knows that how brilliant you are.
但是蒂娜，你得承认，用最好的一种方式，你就像特洛伊木马一样潜入了进去，你知道的，玛西和洛恩进来，他们大概想，好吧，他们甚至都没看你或者别的什么。然后你来了，你提交了作品包。显而易见，麦凯想要，你知道的，他知道你是多么才华横溢。
You come, you start submitting on SNL and then your talent just shows through and you end up getting it in spite of them and become like the biggest star on the show for many years. That's gotta feel kind of gratifying. I don't mean that in a shitty way, but it must feel like, yeah,
你来了，你开始在 SNL 提交作品，然后你的才华自然流露，最终你无视他们的初衷得到了这个机会，并在多年里成为了节目里最大的明星。这感觉一定挺有成就感的。我不是用贬义来说的，但这感觉一定像是，是的，我一直都知道我真的能做到这一点。
I always knew I could do this in a real way. It was, you know, yeah, the long grift sort of paid off. I mean, there's a couple of factors. There's like the team of gay scientists that fixed my appearance, you know. That's a title of your next series, by the way. And then like, I always say don't underestimate how gloriously lazy Lauren is about casting
你知道的，是的，长期的潜心磨炼总算有了回报。我的意思是，有几个因素。比如说有一支由同性恋科学家组成的团队改造了我的外表，你知道的。顺便说一句，这可以作为你下一部剧的剧名。然后就像，我总是说不要低估洛恩在选角上有多么惊人的懒惰，
because this is like Conan, like, do you think someone was like going all over town and being like, where's a pasty seven foot redhead that we can put, that we can give a talk show to? I was like, no, he was around the office, being funny around the office. And that's the same thing happened here. It was like, we need to new update anchors.
因为就像柯南一样，你觉得会有人跑遍全城然后问，哪里能找到一个身高七尺、皮肤苍白、我们可以给他开个脱口秀的红头发家伙吗？我当时就想，不，他当时就在办公室周围，在办公室里表现得很搞笑。这里发生的事情也是一样。当时的情况是，我们需要新的《周六夜现场播报》主播。
Like, let me look inside my own eyelids for like, who's available. Do you prefer one over the other acting and writing? Like, do you miss performing when you're not in a writer's room and vice versa? Writing is like, it's only fun to have written something. Like, writing is only fun after it's over. Right.
就像，让我闭上眼睛在脑子里搜寻一下，看看谁有空。你更喜欢表演还是写作？比如当你不在编剧室时，你会怀念表演吗，反之亦然？写作就像是，只有在“已经写完”的时候才有趣。也就是说，写作只有在结束之后才好玩。对。
Performing is like fun while it's happening. And then for me, if you're me, you usually look back after and go, oh, yeah, that wasn't. Yeah, that would include myself in that, yeah. Do you think that, yeah? Yeah, no, I just like, I beat myself up all the time. But you're crazy. So it is common for the weekend anchor
表演则是在发生的过程中很有趣。然后对我来说，如果是我的话，你通常在事后回想，然后会说，哦，是的，那其实……是的，我会把自己也算在内，对。你觉得，是的？对，不，我只是，我总是对自己百般挑剔。但你很疯狂。所以对于周末主播来说，
to not be a performer, correct? Yeah. Well, Chevy was first, right? He was mostly just that. He was not a performer that much on the show, was he? Not too much. He was a little bit. Right.
不是表演出身，这很常见吗？对。嗯，Chevy是第一个，对吧？他基本上也就是那样。他在节目里其实不怎么演小品，对吧？不太怎么演。他稍微演了一点。对。
He did Gerald Ford and some commercials. Is it common for the head writer to be the anchor? It is now, because Joest and Che are the head writers, I think, among like. And Seth as well was, yes. Seth was, yes, yeah. You know what I really did learn that time, too, was that I learned, you know, after Jimmy left,
他演过杰拉尔德·福特还有一些商业广告。首席编剧担任主播，这很常见吗？现在很常见，因为 Joest 和 Che 是首席编剧，在……之中。Seth 也是，是的。Seth 也是，是的，对。你知道我当时也真正学到了什么吗，那就是我了解到，你知道的，在 Jimmy 离开之后，
and then Warren was like, well, do you want to do it by yourself? And I thought like, well, I'm supposed to want to do it by myself, right? Yeah. And I think we even did like that. And then at the last minute, I was like, I don't want to, I want to do it with Amy.
然后洛恩就问，嗯，你想自己一个人干吗？当时我想，好吧，我应该想要自己一个人干，对吧？对。而且我想我们甚至还排练过那种形式。然后在最后一分钟，我改变主意了，我说我不要，我想和 Amy 一起。
And I realized that's why I learned that I don't, I don't work a single. Right. Yeah, I kind of remember that. I remember that first, that was a very late breaking decision. Very late, rudely late. And then it turned out to be obviously great.
我意识到，也就是在那时我明白了我不能单干。对。对，我有点记起来了。我记得那是个非常临时的决定。非常临时，粗鲁地临时。然后结果显然非常棒。
And you guys, that was such a exciting time for the show. You guys were so good. And it was so much fun. And it was fun to have a front row seat to that. It was amazing. You guys at that kind of, right in that same year, you guys were doing mean girls at the same time,
你们俩，那对节目来说是个多么激动人心的时代啊。你们俩太棒了。而且太有趣了。能有幸坐在第一排见证这一切真是太棒了。太惊人了。你们就在那个，正好在同一年，你们一边在做《贱女孩》，
that first year you started, right? You guys were shooting while you were doing update. Remember that, it was crazy. Maybe. I think you're probably, I'm going to assume that you're right about that. So many things, I dragged to trash. I don't remember a lot of things.
你们开始的那第一年，对吧？你们一边做播报一边在拍电影。还记得吗，太疯狂了。可能吧。我想你大概，我假设你在这点上是对的。有太多事情了，我把Dratch拖下水了。很多事情我都不记得了。
I dragged to trash. That's the name of my biography. But that seems right. Tina, are you still a fan of SNL? Of course you are, I'm sure you are. Is there anybody that you just are completely drawn to that's on now that you're like, want to work with or? Oh yeah, well that's,
我把Dratch拖下水了。这就是我的自传名字。不过听起来好像没错。蒂娜，你现在还是 SNL 的粉丝吗？当然是的，我敢肯定你是。有没有哪位现在还在节目里的人完全吸引了你的注意，让你想和他合作，或者？哦，当然，这就是，
I am a fan and what's really exciting now is my older daughter Alice is 15. And so we stay up and watch together. So that's fun to like, be at that age with her where she's into it, you know. And, yeah, I mean. Does she go back and watch your episodes? No.
我是个粉丝，现在最让人兴奋的是我的大女儿 Alice 15岁了。所以我们俩会熬夜一起看。和她一起处在她这个对这节目感兴趣的年纪，这真的很有趣，你知道的。而且，是的，我的意思是。她会回头看你当年的节目吗？不。
No. No. Do your kids want to watch your set up? No, they don't give it up. My kids, my wife, no one thinks I'm doing anything but counting paper clips when I'm working. That's healthy though. That's healthy I think.
不。不。你的孩子们想看你的作品吗？不，他们根本不理这茬。我的孩子们，我的妻子，没有人觉得我在工作时是在干别的，除了在数回形针。不过这样挺健康的。我觉得这很健康。
Yeah. And they watch everything. They watch, should you watch Parks and Rec? 100%. Yeah. The office, 100%. Yeah, exactly. So yeah, I mean, I'm still a fan of Keenan.
对。而且他们什么都看。他们看，你们看《公园与游憩》吗？100%。对。《办公室》，100%。对，完全如此。所以，是的，我的意思是，我依然是 Keenan 的粉丝。
That's never going to change. I think Chris Red is super funny. Yeah, Chris Red. Chris Red, Chris Red was on Will and Grace and he was supposed to be a recurring character. And as they were trying to make his deal, he got a call like a week later. And like a week or two later,
这一点永远不会变。我觉得 Chris Red 超级搞笑。对，Chris Red。Chris Red，Chris Red 曾出演过《威尔与格蕾丝》，他本应是一个常驻角色。就在他们试图敲定他的合约时，大约一周后他接到了一个电话。然后大约一周或两周后，
he's on SNL. I was like, that's so crazy. It's like a couple episodes of Will and Grace. That is crazy. So Tina, how do you manage being so great at what it is that you do and physically? Like how do you decide where to point your work? I mean, you can be, you can do so many different things,
他就上了 SNL。我当时就想，这太疯狂了。就像拍了几集《威尔与格蕾丝》就去了。太疯狂了。所以蒂娜，你是如何做到在你的领域如此优秀，并且在体力上……比如你如何决定将精力倾注在哪里？我的意思是，你可以做这么多不同的事情，
whether it's television or film or theater, musicals, on camera, behind camera. Like I would imagine it would be somewhat burdensome to try to figure out what to prioritize. I mean, I think TV sort of where I'm most comfortable because I feel like it's the most interesting place right now. There's more interesting things happening in TV, especially for comedy.
无论是电视、电影、戏剧、音乐剧，还是台前幕后。我想，试图弄清楚该优先处理什么，应该会是一种不小的负担吧。我的意思是，我觉得电视大概是我最感舒适的地方，因为我觉得这是目前最有趣的地方。电视领域正在发生更多有趣的事情，特别是对喜剧而言。
I feel like the movies is kind of glacially paced. And it's not that I don't want to do movies, but it also just feels like there's so many more chances for people to fuck it up in movies. Well, it takes seven years to make a movie. It takes seven years and takes seven years to shoot it. Don't you always find that like, there's nothing more boring in a lot of ways
我觉得电影界的节奏简直慢如冰川。倒不是说我不想拍电影，但感觉在电影里大家搞砸的机会实在太多了。拍一部电影得花七年时间。花七年时间，光是拍摄就要花七年。难道你总是觉得，在很多方面没有什么比拍电影、在电影片场更无聊的事了？
than making a movie and being on a movie set. It's so slow and it's not conducive to that immediacy that you have when you're making a show, when you've got to shoot nine pages in a day and you got to get the scene and it's got, you've got to move, it's got to be quick. And that lends itself to being funnier rather than shooting one side of it, you know, for one day.
节奏太慢了，而且不利于你拍电视剧时那种即兴感——拍电视剧时你一天得拍九页剧本，你得把场景拿下来，动作得快，节奏得紧凑。那种节奏能带来更多笑料，而不是像拍电影那样，一个角度拍上一整天，然后，你知道的，只拍了不到半页剧本。那简直糟透了。
And then, you know, you shoot like three eighths of a page. Like there's the worst. And in TV, you know, you did 30 rock. You guys would jam through though, you'd have those huge packed days with just like a million scenes and you just got to get it. Also, we all joke about like,
而在电视界，你知道的，你拍了《我为喜剧狂》。你们以前总是赶进度，会有那种排得满满当当的巨大工作日，有无数个场景，你必须搞定它。而且，我们总是开玩笑说，
remember when we used to make 22 episodes of things? That's like ridiculous now. Like everyone makes like three episodes and collects their awards. Don't you think those days are, those days seem like they're over, don't you think? The 22 episode day? I think so.
还记得我们以前一拍就是22集的时候吗？现在想来简直太离谱了。现在每个人拍个三集就能去领奖了。你不觉得那些日子，那些日子好像已经一去不复返了吗？22集的年代？我想是的。
Or the 100 episodes of a show. Yeah. I think so. What about writing books? Was that, is that a good time pace for you? Or is that somewhat glacial as well? I just did that the one time. And I remember I was like doing 30 rock at the same time.
或者一部剧拍100集的年代。是的，我想是的。写书呢？那对你来说是一个节奏很好的体验吗？还是说那也跟冰川一样慢？我只写过一次。我记得我当时一边在拍《我为喜剧狂》，
I was doing, I think I started it. I remember I was on the set of date night with Steve Carell and I just had like a notebook on this. I was like, yeah, I guess I said I would write this book. And then as short as that book is, I felt like it near about killed me because again, I don't work a single. And I was so used to having a writer's room.
我一边在弄，我记得我当时在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的《约会之夜》片场，我手里就拿了个笔记本。我当时就想，好吧，我猜我答应过要写这本书。而且尽管那本书很短，我觉得它差点把我累死，因为同样地，我不能单干。而且我太习惯有个编剧室了。
And I was like, not so much that it was more work, but it was just so vulnerable of like, if this book comes out and people are like, boo, it's a hundred percent my fault. It's a hundred percent a rejection of me personally. It's not a novel. It's just like, here's what my deal is. And if people were like, boo,
我的意思倒不是说它工作量更大，而是它太让人感到脆弱了——如果这本书出版了，大家反应说“嘘——”，那百分之百是我的错。百分之百是对我个人的拒绝。这不是一本小说。这只是在说，这就是我的现状。如果大家反应说“嘘——”，
I've never felt so nervous about anything. I walk into like a grocery store and people go, boo. Sure. Boo. But that's just because they've seen your work. That's what I'm saying. Yeah, that's what I'm saying. That's what I'm saying.
我从来没有对任何事情感到如此紧张。我走进杂货店，人们走过来发出“嘘——”的声音。当然。嘘——。但那只是因为他们看过你的作品。这就是我想说的。对，这就是我想说的。这就是我想说的。
Tina? Well, yeah, sorry. Go ahead, go ahead. Are you in like an old person's bathroom? What is that? By the way, you should know. You should know. So this is my home booth.
蒂娜？好吧，是的，抱歉。你继续，你继续。你是在老人的浴室里吗？那是什么？顺便说一句，你们应该知道。你们应该知道。所以这是我的家庭录音亭。
And these are actually handles for a bathtub, no joke. Because usually when I record my real video is I'm standing up and I like to lean and hold on. So I had the guy get these, and they are for somebody who needs help getting in and out of a tub. Now, how much harder or what would you have to navigate to become to do what you do today?
这些其实是浴缸的扶手，不开玩笑。因为我平时录制真正的视频时，我是站着的，我喜欢靠着并抓着东西。所以我让工人装了这个，这些本来是给需要人搀扶上下浴缸的人准备的。那么，如果你要像今天这样达到你现在的成就，你需要克服多少困难或如何去应对？
If you were starting out and you were 22 today and trying to get into comedy, fuck, right? Well, you get, yeah. Advice, right? Not even advice, just like what would you do to yourself? Like how would you do it if you were graduating? I'm not necessarily saying,
如果你刚出道，今天22岁，正试图闯入喜剧界，那可太操蛋了，对吧？好吧，你会，对。给点建议，对吧？甚至不是建议，只是假设你自己重新来过？比如如果你刚毕业，你会怎么做？我未必是在说，
hey, to young writers out there, listen, like literally what would you do? Yeah, that's a good question. What would I do? I probably would be trying to blow up on TikTok or something, right? I would be cutting out the middleman, which, listen, it's worked well in porn.
嘿，给年轻的编剧们听着，听好了——我是说字面意思，你会怎么做？是的，这是个好问题。我会怎么做？我大概会试着在 TikTok 上火一把吧，对吧？我会跳过中间商，听着，这招在色情行业挺管用的。
Sure, right. It means Hugh Hefner anymore, right? Yeah. It seems like, I mean, unless I'm wrong, it seems like people on TikTok really wanna be in television or film, and the people in television or film aren't making that money anymore,
确实，对吧？现在不需要休·海夫纳了，对吧？是的。看起来，除非我搞错了，感觉 TikTok 上的那些人真的想去拍电视或电影，而电视或电影界的人又赚不到以前那种钱了，
so they wanna go blow up on TikTok. It's, don't you feel that way? Yeah, I think broadcast TV, especially doesn't mean, to my kids, that doesn't mean anything to them. They don't understand what's happening. Is there still, I'm gonna sound like a real old man here, can you still make a bunch of money on social media,
所以他们想去 TikTok 上爆红。难道你不这么觉得吗？是的，我认为广播电视尤其对我的孩子们来说，那毫无意义。他们根本不明白发生了什么。是不是还有，我在这里听起来真像个老头子，你还能在社交媒体上赚到一大笔钱吗，
like saying, I like this kind of chocolate. I say this kind of, like, I think so. Right, that's a whole industry, right? I think so, yeah. Like taste, that's not what taste makers are called, is it? Is that what? Influencers?
比如发话说，我喜欢这种巧克力。我说我喜欢这种，比如，我想是的。对，那是一整条产业链，对吧？我想是的，对。就像品味，这不叫品味制造者，对吧？那是叫什么？网红？
Influencers, right. And like people have agents for that and stuff? Dude, take yourself out back and just end it, man. This is fucking, by the way, this is a great opportunity to mention, you said chocolate, Jason, for us to mention Reese's. Jason's been asking me to reach out to the people at Reese's cause he wants free peanut butter cups because
网红，对吧？而且人们为此还有经纪人和什么的？老兄，你自己去后院了结了吧，伙计。这他妈的，顺便说一句，这是一个极好的机会来提及，你刚才说了巧克力，杰森，正好让我们提一下 Reese's 花生酱杯。杰森一直在求我联系 Reese's 的人，因为他想要免费的花生酱杯，
he doesn't make any money over on the Ozarks. But I'm so sick and tired of hearing your dumb voice, sell candy on TV. And I'm like, if I gotta listen to it, if I gotta listen to it, then why don't you get me a free box of those, the peanut butter cups that are wrapped in peanut butter with the peanut butter inside.
因为他在《黑钱胜地》里根本赚不到什么钱。但我已经厌倦了听你那蠢声音在电视上卖糖果了。我想，如果我非得听，如果我非得听这广告，那你为什么不给我弄一箱免费的那些花生酱杯呢——就是那种外面裹着花生酱、里面也有花生酱的。
It's double triple peanut butter, and I'm not sorry, whatever it is. I need some of that for free for having to listen to your crap. Great, okay, I got it. I wrote it down and they're obviously listening right now. So thank you, everybody at Reese's and to Jason Bateman. Should I give my address over the air here?
那是双倍三倍的花生酱，我才不道歉呢，不管它到底是什么。既然我不得不听你的废话，我得拿点免费的来当补偿。太好了，好吧，我记下了。而且他们显然现在正在收听。所以谢谢大家，Reese's 的所有人，还有杰森·贝特曼。我是不是应该在节目里公布我的地址？
Yeah, give your address. Number one, Deadline Hollywood Way. Tina, did you ever imagine it would be this amazing being on this podcast? I mean, I thought about it. Thought about saying no, and then. My tip on Reese's though, this is my tip on all candy.
对，把你的地址报出来。好莱坞大道死线街1号。蒂娜，你有没有想过上这个播客能这么棒？我的意思是，我想过。想过拒绝，然后。不过我对 Reese's 的建议是，这是我对所有糖果的建议。
Sure. Whenever there's holiday candy, where it's like the Reese's shaped like Santa Claus, always buy that candy because it's fresher. Fresher, nice. Cause they just made it. You could get a regular candy bar. That's a good point.
每当有节日糖果的时候，比如做成圣诞老人形状的 Reese's，一定要买那种糖果，因为它们更新鲜。更新鲜，不错。因为那是刚做出来的。你完全可能买到一根普通的糖果棒，
It could have been in the CVS for seven months. Really good point. We often ask this question of people who are in the public eye, who have children. Would you do your kids, I wanna do what mom and or dad does, or would you discourage them from getting it, or you just say follow your dreams and I'll support you? It's funny, you should ask that.
那可能在 CVS 便利店里已经放了七个月了。非常有道理。我们经常向那些身为父母的公众人物问这样一个问题。你会让你的孩子们去做妈妈和/或者爸爸做的事吗，还是会劝阻他们别干这个，或者你只会说“去追求你们的梦想吧，我支持你们”？很有趣，你竟然会问这个。
Our older daughter, I think if anything, maybe would be interested in directing, I think she would be horrified to perform. And I never, when she was a little kid, I think all little kids think they want to. And I think I let her be, I think she was in some still photographs, Alice. She played young Liz Lemon,
我们的大女儿，如果要说的话，也许会对导演感兴趣，我想她对于去表演会感到惊恐万分。而且我从没——在她还是个小不点的时候，我想所有小孩子都觉得自己想演。而且我想我随她去，我想她拍过一些静态照片，Alice。她演过年轻时的 Liz Lemon，
but in a series of photographs at the end of 30 Rock. And that was like, that's enough. Like let's keep it measured. And then this other one that you, no, no, what I'm dealing with. During the pandemic, it came up, we worked for Girls 5 Eva, we had to cast a kid to play busy Phillips and Andrew Rannell's child,
不过是在《我为喜剧狂》大结局的一系列照片里。这就够了。我们还是适可而止吧。然后另一个，就是你刚才，不，不，我正在应付的这个。在疫情期间，这事儿出现了，我们在弄《Girls Five Ever》，我们必须选一个小孩来演 Busy Phillips 和 Andrew Rannells 的孩子，
who was like a little YouTube villain. And I had always said that when I was like, you know what? That's a Nelly. I got a Nelly Olsen right here. Um. Jason knows Nelly. I know, oh, small world, she became a stand up. I believe me.
那是个有点像 YouTube 小恶魔的角色。我当时就说过，你知道吗？这就是个内莉（Nelly）。我这儿正好有个内莉·奥尔森。Jason认识内莉。我知道，世界真小，她后来去搞单口喜剧了。相信我。
Really? I loved her. Yeah, I remember like, she became a stand up for a while, right? Al, I want to say Alison Angrum? Is that right? Dude, if you don't know. Oh my God.
真的吗？我挺喜欢她的。对，我记得，她当过一段时间单口喜剧演员，对吧？Al，我想是 Alison Angrum？是这样吗？老兄，如果你不知道。天哪。
Alison Angrum, did I say that? I said it right, right? Alison Angrum, yeah. Yeah. There you go. Anyway, so I let her audition for this part because it was sort of like- Wait, you made your daughter read?
Alison Angrum，我是这么说的吗？我没说错吧？Alison Angrum，对。对。这就对了。不管怎样，所以我让她去为这个角色试镜，因为这有点像——等等，你让你女儿去念台词？
Of course I made her read. Yeah, because I thought that was gonna be the end of it. And then her audition was pretty good. And- I thought I was the bad parent on this one. Oh, it was gonna get worse. And then, so then, and then she did pretty well. And then there was another kid who was like
我当然让她念台词了。对，因为我以为那样就能打发她了。结果她的试镜表现相当不错。然后——我还以为我是这节目里糟糕的家长呢。哦，更糟糕的还在后面呢。然后，接着她表现得挺好。当时还有另一个小孩，
an actual experienced kid. And we're like, well, this, and I was like, this will be good for her. She, you know, we could hire the kid with more experience. And then, and so I had to tell her like, well, you did really well. And I was making it up. I was like, you were in the top three.
是个真正有经验的小孩。我们就在想，好吧，这，我当时想，这对她来说是个锻炼。她，你知道的，我们可以雇那个更有经验的小孩。然后，所以我不得不告诉她，嗯，你表现得真的很棒。我当时是胡编的。我当时说，你进入前三名了。
And, but, you know, we had, and then she was like, basically it was like, I didn't book it. And she was like, you didn't book it? Well, I was like, you're half TFA. And that bitch never booked anything. And so I was like, you didn't book it. But then, because it was the pandemic,
但是，你知道的，我们有，然后她就，基本上就是，我没选上。然后她说，你没选上？好吧，我说，你身上有一半蒂娜·菲的血统。那个碧池从来没选上过任何角色。所以我当时就说，你没选上。但是后来，因为碰上疫情，
this other poor kid, they were like, well, she can work as a local hire, but she's in Michigan right now. And the quarantine, it fell apart. And so then I was like, back up. All right, homegirl, you're up. So she's in it. And now we're faced, now, and it was at the time,
另一个可怜的小孩，他们说，嗯，她可以作为本地雇员来工作，但她现在在密歇根。而隔离政策，计划泡汤了。所以然后我就说，备用方案。好了，大姐头，该你上场了。所以她演了。现在我们面临着，当时的情况是，
it was like, you get to leave the house and get a test and work during quarantine. And I will say she was incredibly professional. I said, she was like a little bit like mommy. She was like very prepared and a little dead eyed. You've all acted with me. That's what it is. But she was dead.
这就意味着你可以离开家去做个检测，并在隔离期间工作。我得说她极其专业。我说，她有点像妈妈。她非常专业，准备充分，而且眼神有点空洞。你们都跟我演过戏。就是那种感觉。但她眼神空洞。天哪，如果她听到这段剪辑，她会谋杀我的。
And a little dead eyed. My God, if she hears the clip of that, she'll murder me. So listen, Tina, I'm kind of obsessed with horrible theater stories and theater stories gone wrong. I have so many. Do you have like a favorite or like a play you were in or at Second City or something? Oh, a favorite theater horror story.
所以听着，蒂娜，我有点着迷于可怕的剧场故事和搞砸了的剧场故事。我有太多这样的故事了。你有没有什么最喜欢的，或者你在第二城剧团时经历过或参演过的一出戏？哦，最喜欢的剧场恐怖故事。
I do have a pretty good theater horror story. This is from high school theater. Yes. So, okay, in my high school, I played Van Helsing in Dracula because feminism. Did you borrow Paul as a gray spray? I probably did. Nice callback.
我还真有一个挺不错的剧场恐怖故事。这是高中戏剧里的。好吧，在我的高中，我在《吸血鬼德古拉》里扮演范海辛，因为女权主义。你是不是借了 Paula 的灰色发胶？我大概借了。好一个回扣。
Nice callback. And so, okay, so let me think about this. So I was Van Helsing in Dracula and we did like a total of two performances and everything went wrong. And I can't remember this story. Like the first thing that kind of went wrong would be like, our theater was a thrust stage and the seats went up.
好一个呼应。所以，好吧，让我想想。我在《吸血鬼德古拉》里演范海辛，我们总共演了差不多两场，结果每件事都出了岔子。我记不清这个故事了。比如第一件出岔子的事大概是，我们的剧场是个伸出式舞台，座位是往上延伸的。
Is that arena? So like, tiered? Tiered, yeah. Like so the stage was on the ground and the audience was up. And we had like a rubber bat on a like a very long string like scene one, the bat's supposed to fly by, the bat gets stuck.
那是圆形剧场吗？就像阶梯式的？阶梯式的，对。舞台在地面上，观众在上面。我们有一只橡胶蝙蝠挂在一根非常长的细线上——第一幕，蝙蝠本该飞过去，结果蝙蝠卡住了。
It's just dangling on the stage the rest of the night. We're like, oh, that's not good. Then I give some big speech. There's this guy, Harker says to me like, professor, what is a vampire? And I give a speech like, I give like a page and a half speech of what is a vampire? And this kid was just like not listening.
它就在舞台上晃荡了整整一晚。我们当时想，哦，这可不太妙。然后我发表了一段慷慨激昂的演讲。有个叫 Harker 的家伙对我说，教授，什么是吸血鬼？我发表了一段演讲，发表了一页半关于“什么是吸血鬼”的演讲？而这个小孩根本没在听。
So he goes, what is a vampire? And I give the whole speech. And at the end of it, he looks at me and goes, but professor, what is a vampire? And he gave me this same cue again. Then the kid who played Dracula was this kid, John Doyle, who was like very like Bon Jovi based. Like his personality was Bon Jovi based.
所以他问，什么是吸血鬼？于是我发表了整段演讲。在演讲结束时，他看着我问，但是教授，什么是吸血鬼？他又给我抛了同一个台词cue。然后扮演德古拉的那个小孩是 John Doyle，他的风格非常像邦·乔维（Bon Jovi）。他的个性完全是邦·乔维风格的。
Beautiful hair. Rocker hair, beautiful hair. His mom was a hairdresser. And his mom was also a professional and Jillian impersonator, side story. Anyway. Let's get back, we'll double back to that. We'll double back.
一头漂亮的头发。摇滚乐手的发型，漂亮的头发。他妈妈是个美发师。题外话，他妈妈还是个专业吉莉安（Jillian）模仿秀演员。总之。我们言归正传，待会儿再绕回这个话题。我们待会儿再绕回来。
And so John, you know, because he was like, he was like, oh, he takes rock singing lessons in New York. Like he was cool guy. He was not an athlete. And so there's a scene where there's a mirror and Dracula like sees the mirror and he's supposed to throw this like chalice or something and smash the mirror.
所以约翰，你知道的，因为他当时觉得自己挺酷，在纽约上过摇滚声乐课。他可不是个运动员。所以有个场景是这样的：有一面镜子，德古拉看到这面镜子，本该把某个圣杯之类的东西扔出去，把镜子砸碎。
And so John being like not an athlete and in this open arena, like I go a mirror and then he like throws the thing, misses the mirror entirely. So then I'm like trying to improvise like, what am I supposed to say? And then a full like 20 seconds later, a little techie kid comes out
然后约翰由于不是个运动员，又站在这个开放的舞台上，心想“我有面镜子了”，于是把那东西一扔，完全没砸中镜子。当时我在那儿努力即兴发挥：“我该说什么台词？”结果过了整整20秒，一个小技术员
like in full view of the audience with a hammer from behind and smashes the mirror. Oh, at one point also, then the set caught on fire a little bit. Jesus. There was like a little flash pot and the fake rocks of the castle were foam and started to catch on fire.
大摇大摆地当着观众的面，手里拿着锤子从后面走出来，把镜子砸碎了。哦，还有一次，当时布景还着了一点小火。天呐。有个小闪光弹，城堡的假石头是用泡沫做的，开始着火了。
And then my dad who had been a fireman and did not fuck around, he stood up and he was like, fire. And we were like, okay. Like he stood up in the audience and he over. This is like all backed one. And then put the fire out and continued. It's a longer story than you want it.
然后我爸——他当过消防员，办事绝不含糊——他站起来喊道：“着火了！”我们当时就想：好吧。他就在观众席上站起来，然后走过去。这都是在第一幕发生的。接着把火扑灭了，演出继续。这故事比你想的要长。
And then again, the techies, like there's a part where like there's a techie just like in a bay window, just like in full view of the audience with a fog machine, just being like knowing he's just like a total hero. And then the end of the whole thing ended with like Van Helsing kills Dracula with a spike through the heart.
然后又是那些技术员，有一幕里，有个技术员就呆在一个飘窗里，完全暴露在观众视野中，拿着一台造雾机，觉得自己简直是个大英雄。整场演出最后是以范·海辛用一根长钉刺穿心脏杀死德古拉结束的。
And it was, and I'm down and I'm like acting so hard and I'm doing this whole speech. And then I just hear laughter. And I was like, this, this can't be good. This is the end of the whole play. Because again, the stage flat audience here, I was like lightning flushing. I'm killing the vampire.
当时呢，我倒在地上，演得极其卖力，正在发表长篇大论。然后我只听到了一阵笑声。我想：“这、这可不妙。这可是整出戏的结尾啊。”因为舞台和观众席是平的，我当时心想：电闪雷鸣的，我正在消灭吸血鬼呢。
And I look up and just a toddler has wandered onto the stage. No. Toward me. And that's how not scary it was. The toddler joined us. That's my story. That's hilarious.
结果我抬起头，发现有个蹒跚学步的小 toddler 居然晃悠到了舞台上。天哪。朝我走过来。可见这戏一点也不吓人。那个小孩加入我们了。这就是我的故事。太搞笑了。
By the way, you mentioned your dad. I always think about this. I met your parents a couple of times, but I remember your dad, I remember going to your wedding and we had only met a couple of times at going to your wedding. Your dad described me as...
话说回来，你提到了你爸。我经常想起这事。我见过你父母好几次，但我记得你爸，我记得去参加你的婚礼，当时我们其实只见过几次面，你去参加你的婚礼时，你爸是这么形容我的……
He's like, that guy's Brooks Brothers handsome, right? He said, no, he's an arrow shirt. Do you remember that? Yeah, my dad was very taken with Will. He's like, oh God, that guy, that guy looks like an arrow shirt model. But it was very specific. Do you remember arrow shirts?
他说：“那家伙长得很有布克兄弟（Brooks Brothers）男装的帅气，对吧？”他说：“不，他长得像箭牌衬衫（Arrow shirt）广告里的。”你还记得吗？对，我爸对威尔印象深刻。他当时说：“哦天哪，这家伙，这家伙长得就像箭牌衬衫的模特。”而且形容得特别具体。你还记得箭牌衬衫吗？
I was like, look at this year's catalog. Like that guy's an arrow shirt. And I was like, He just made them for thick dudes. Is that what the, was it special for? Excuse me? Nothing? Oh no, Will was thin then.
我当时就说：“看看今年的产品目录吧。这伙计就像个箭牌衬衫模特。”我当时心想……他这话是不是专为那些身材魁梧的壮汉说的？是吗，这词儿有什么特殊的？不好意思？没什么？哦不，威尔那时候很瘦。
He was really thin then. I was thin then. I don't believe it. I was really thin. Tina, because of your theater background, would you ever want to do multi-cam? Now for the audience difference between multi-cam and single-cam is single-cam,
他那时候真的很瘦。我当时很瘦。我才不信呢。我真的挺瘦的。蒂娜，凭你的戏剧背景，你有没有想过拍多机位情景喜剧？现在给观众科普一下多机位和单机位的区别，单机位就是没有现场观众，
there's no audience, multi-cam, there's a live studio audience. That's when you hear laughing, like Cheers and Will and Grace and Friends and Sonfeld and all those. Would you ever want to do a multi-cam? It seems like you'd be perfect for that. Yeah, I do think it'd be so fun.
多机位则有现场演播室观众。也就是你会听到笑声的那种，比如《干杯酒吧》（Cheers）、《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）、《老友记》（Friends）、《宋飞正传》（Seinfeld）这些。你有没有想过拍一部多机位喜剧？感觉你非常适合那种形式。对啊，我觉得那肯定特别好玩。
I feel like in some ways it's hard to... Will and Grace was one of the last ones that was especially on NBC, they don't really do them so much anymore. And I also have reached an age where I can't really be photographed from the waist down. Yeah, not true. So like, but I do think it'd be fun.
我觉得在某种程度上很难……《威尔和格蕾丝》是最后一批这类剧集之一，尤其是NBC的剧，他们现在基本上不大拍这种了。而且我也到了这个年纪，从腰部以下已经不太适合上镜了。行啦，才没这回事。所以呢，不过我还是觉得那会挺好玩的。
But wouldn't it be great to hear all that laughter through the masks? Or if you don't want to be in one, just like create one and write one. I think you'd be so amazing. Are you saying that you want Tina to create a multi-cam for you? No.
但隔着口罩听到那些笑声，难道不是很棒吗？或者如果你不想参演，干脆自己创作并写一部。我觉得你肯定会特别厉害。你是说你想让蒂娜为你创作一部多机位喜剧吗？才没有。
What about hosting a talk show? Would you ever do that, Tina? It seems to me like you'd be fantastic at that. Oh, thank you. I don't know that. I think I'm very shy. I think to me it sounds super stressful. I've never wanted to pursue that.
那主持一档脱口秀呢？蒂娜，你有没有想过做那个？在我看来，你在这方面绝对棒极了。哦，谢谢。我不知道。我觉得我很害羞。对我来说这听起来压力太大了。我从来没想过要去追求那个。
I'm really shy too. Yeah, we can tell. I am. I don't like being the center of attention. Well, and also with those kind of late night talk shows, like that's a grind, that's like... But I remember when you were doing 30 Rock, I mean, you came off SNL, which was a grind
我也真的很害羞。对，看得出来。我是认真的。我其实不喜欢成为注意力的焦点。嗯，而且对于那种深夜脱口秀来说，那真是一场苦差事，就像……但我记得你当年在做《我为喜剧狂》（30 Rock）的时候，你是从《周六夜现场》（SNL）出来的，那也是个苦差事，
because you were a head writer and you were doing update and it was a lot, a lot, a lot, and especially leading right up until, you know, 2008 and everything that was going on. Oh, sorry, you were already doing 30 Rock at that point, but you were doing so much, then you go to 30 Rock and it just kind of amps it up even more because you're show-running 30 Rock
因为你是首席编剧，还要做“周末新闻播报”（Update），工作量极其巨大，尤其是临近2008年以及当时发生的种种事情的时候。哦，抱歉，你当时其实已经在做《我为喜剧狂》了，但你当时要做的事情太多了，接着你又去搞《我为喜剧狂》，这把工作强度进一步升级了，因为你既是《我为喜剧狂》的剧集运作人（show-runner），
and you're writing it on and then you're starring in it as well and having 16-hour days. So you're not pulling all-nighters every night, but you are going 18 hours or 17 hours a day. Like, that was fucking really rough, right? For many years in there? It was insane.
还要写剧本，同时还要主演，每天要工作16个小时。所以你倒不是每天晚上都要通宵熬夜，但你一天要干18个小时或17个小时。天哪，那真的超级辛苦，对吧？在那好多年里？那简直疯狂。
First of all, also, if you hear weird breathing sounds, it's the dog, it's not me. Listen, does she now has her dog, her white, what is it, a kaka poo? He's a poodle. He's just a straight poo. He's a poodle. Straight poo.
首先，还有，如果你听到奇怪的喘息声，那是狗，不是我。听着，她现在养了她的狗，她的那只白色的，是什么来着，卡波犬（kaka poo）？他是贵宾犬。他就是纯种贵宾。他是贵宾犬。纯种贵宾。
Yeah, looking back on that kind of stuff. I didn't mean to say that you looked tired in those years. I just meant to say more that I know that you were very exhausted. You talked about it, like you were like getting crushed. It was insane. What we did, I don't know, we were just, I was at 35 and had some juice left
对，回想起那些事情……我不是说你当年看起来很累。我只是想说，我知道你当时精疲力竭。你当时也聊过这个，就感觉自己快被压垮了。太疯狂了。我们做的事，我不知道，我当时35岁，还有点精力，
and doing 22 episodes. And also my baby, Alice was one when we started and it was crazy. It was crazy. I look back and shudder at just what we, yeah. Did you enjoy the shutdown and the pandemic to kind of recharge a little bit or did you stay super-duper busy?
还要拍22集。而且我的宝贝女儿爱丽丝（Alice）我们刚开拍时才一岁，简直太疯狂了。太疯狂了。现在回想起来，对于我们当时所经历的，我不禁打了个寒颤。是啊。你喜欢那种因停工和疫情而稍微充电休息一下的时期吗，还是说你一直忙得不可开交？
I wouldn't say enjoyed it. I mean, like, yeah, it's always one of those things where if you're like, oh, I'm lucky enough that nobody in my family died. So like, it's okay to then just quietly say like it was nice that we were together. I guess what I meant is enjoyed the period that you could not work.
我不会用“享受”这个词。我的意思是，对，这总归是那种情况：如果你足够幸运，家里没有人因病去世，那么你就可以默默地对自己说，大家能聚在一起其实挺温馨的。我大概是说，享受那种完全不能工作的时期。
Yeah. Yeah. Nice, right? Yeah, it's kind of nice. I think like I would, I'm ready to retire guys. I'm ready to. Me too, by the way, I was saying the same thing. And I was saying, I was talking about it with,
对。对啊。挺美好的，对吧？对，感觉还挺不错的。我觉得，我已经准备好退休了，伙计们。我已经准备好了。我也是，顺便说一句，我刚才也这么说。我当时还在和……
certainly with Amy too, which she's been feeling the same way, which is just that feeling of like, oh my God, you know, much like you kind of did the same thing had, you know, had Archie went right into Parks and Rec. Yeah. And those first few, when you have, both your girls have those like little babies
当然也跟艾米（Amy）聊过，她也有同感，那种感觉就是，天哪，你知道的，就像你经历过的一样，有了阿奇（Archie）之后马上就去拍了《公园与游憩》（Parks and Rec）。对。在前几年，当你有了，你俩的孩子都还是那种小婴儿的时候，
and you're working those insane hours on those shows, it's crushing. It's like, it's soul crushing because you're not at home as much as you wanna be and you've got little kids and you're trying to fuck balance it all. It just. Right, and it's all, you know,
而你又要在这些剧组里没日没夜地疯狂工作，这简直是摧残。这真的是精神上的摧残，因为你没法像自己希望的那样多陪在家里，你带着小小孩，还试图拼命去平衡这一切。简直……没错，而且这一切，你知道的，
nothing compared to someone who's doing all those same work hours on a job that they hate that doesn't pay well. No, no, no, of course it's the same as being a working parent on any job. But like, just in the sense that like, of any working parent, especially a working mom who's working any job that's taking them long stretches,
和那些在讨厌的工作岗位上、拿着微薄的薪水却要承受同样长工时的人相比，根本不值一提……不不不，当然，作为任何工作岗位上的职场父母，感觉都是一样的。但我的意思是，对于任何职场父母，尤其是那些从事着需要长时间离家的工作的职场妈妈来说，
whatever it is. Yeah. And of course there are a lot of people who can say, well, you get paid really well, like, okay, sure. But like, you're still working all those hours. Yeah. And it's tough, you know. And it's hard to, once you get to stop,
不管那是什么工作。对。当然也有很多人会说，好吧，你们拿的薪水很高啊，这倒也没错。但问题是，你依然要工作那么长时间。对啊。这确实很难，你知道的。而且一旦你停下来，
it's hard to go back. Like I've worked on a couple of things. I did a little small part in this show that Steve Martin and Marty Short have, and was that thing of like, and your pickup is five, 10, and you're like, oh yeah, that used to be every day. Yeah.
就很难再回去了。我后来也客串过几部作品。我在史蒂夫·马丁（Steve Martin）和马蒂·肖特（Marty Short）的那部剧里演了个小角色，当时那种感觉就是，通告时间是早上五点十分，你会心想：“哦对，以前天天都是这样。”是的。
Especially for ladies, because the paired makeup. People have really gotten used to working at home too, right? And in any occupation, I wonder how that's gonna all transition back. I think. I know. I do like to go to an office. I like it too.
尤其是对女性来说，因为要配合化妆。而且大家也真的都习惯在家工作了，对吧？无论在什么行业，我都在想这一切最终会怎么过渡回去。我觉得。我知道。我其实挺喜欢去办公室上班的。我也喜欢。
Right, but five days a week, or would it be great like just two days a week, three days a week? I feel like that's gonna be the transition. Sean, you like going to the office too? I do, I prefer like the old man, nine to five kind of one place, one stop shop. Jason likes that too.
对，但要一周五天吗？还是说像一周只去两天、三天那样不是很棒吗？我觉得这会是未来的过渡方向。肖恩，你也喜欢去办公室吗？我确实喜欢，我更喜欢像老派那种朝九晚五、固定在一个地方的一站式工作模式。杰森也喜欢那样。
I like a routine. Jason likes that too. We had this little company a couple of years ago, we had this shared office, and he'd always be like, you fucking dick, we've got this office, and you're never in here. And I go, well yeah, my dad worked his ass off for 40, 50 years.
我喜欢有规律的生活。杰森也喜欢那样。几年前我们有个小公司，合租了一间办公室，他总会说：“你个混蛋，我们租了这办公室，你却从来不来。”然后我就说：“好吧，我爸辛辛苦苦工作了四0、五十年，
I don't wanna have to do that. Why do you think I do what we do, so that I can not go to an office? So you know what I did? I found a portrait of myself, and I put it behind my desk, so he could look at me even when I was at theirs. That's a true story.
我可不想也那样。你以为我搞我们现在这行是为了什么？不就是为了不用去办公室吗？”所以你知道我做了什么吗？我找了一张我自己的肖像画，把它挂在我的办公桌后面，这样就算我不在，他也能看着我。这是个真事。
That really was county paper clips at that place. Yeah, it really was. So Tina, like you joke about retiring, but of course you're never gonna wanna stop writing, and you're never gonna wanna stop doing that kind of, well, oh really? No, come on. So wait Tina, what would you do though?
那地方真的连回形针都要数着发。对，真的就是这样。所以蒂娜，虽然你开玩笑说要退休，但你肯定永远不会想停止写作，也永远不会想停止从事那种……哦真的吗？得了吧。等等，蒂娜，那你到底会做什么呢？
What is there anything like picture the girls are grown and out, and you and Jeff, and you're at home, and what you still would be writing, or is there something that you'd wanna be doing? I wonder, I so wonder, it's like that thing of you, the improv training, right,
有没有这样一种设想：想象一下女儿们都长大独立了，你和杰夫在家，你依然在写作，还是说有什么其他你想做的事？我很纳闷，我真的很好奇，就像那种即兴表演训练一样，对吧，
you go back to it, and it's like when do you enter a scene? This is the trick, the thing that trips people up, does anyone remember like, when are you supposed to enter a scene? And the answer is when you're needed. It's the only time you're supposed to enter.
你重新审视它，这就好比你什么时候该切入一个场景？这就是诀窍所在，也是最容易把人绊倒的地方。有人还记得吗？你到底应该在什么时候切入一个场景？答案是：当需要你的时候。这是你唯一应该切入的时机。
You're not supposed to enter because you have a funny idea, you're not supposed to enter because it's going well, and you want a piece of it. Well, what about the notion of like you and Jeff just doing just globetrotting, and having some wanderlust,
你切入不是因为你有个搞笑的点子，你切入也不是因为现场气氛正好、你想来分一杯羹。那么，你和杰夫去环球旅行、满足一下对远方的渴望，这种想法怎么样？
and once you guys become empty nesters, just start traveling the world, and knocking down, and getting all cultured. Is that something that's appealing to you, or are you as soft as I am, and you need CNN and Thread Count? Oh yeah, I wanna see a couple places,
一旦你们成了空巢老人，就开始周游世界，去各个地方打卡，培养艺术情操。这种生活对你有吸引力吗？还是说你跟我一样娇气，离不开CNN和高支床单？哦对，我想去看几个地方，
but I don't need to see everywhere. I know I'm increasingly just a homebody. I know, you know what I wish one of us should write is like someone should try to be Neil Simon, right? Like someone should write a play. I nominate you. As if that's easy to do. Yeah, let me just write one of those out.
但我不需要把全世界都看遍。我知道我越来越变成一个恋家的人了。我知道，你知道我希望我们当中谁能写出来吗？就是应该有人试着去当尼尔·西蒙（Neil Simon），对吧？应该有人写一部戏剧。我提名你。说的好像这很容易似的。行吧，那我这就随手写一部出来。
But like to write a comedy, a hard comedy, because I'll tell you what, I go to these Broadway plays, and what passes for a joke, Sean, is like mentioning Brooklyn is a joke. Just the words. Just the words. And you have to do it out, you have to play it out.
但我的意思是，要写一部喜剧，一部硬核喜剧。因为我跟你说实话，我去看了这些百老汇戏剧，肖恩，现在那些所谓的笑话，居然是提一下布鲁克林就算是个笑话。仅仅是靠那些词。仅仅是靠台词。而且你得把它们演出来，你得把它完整地呈现出来。
Brooklyn. What about the films that Neil Simon, they adapted and became like California Suite. Yeah, California Suite, Goodbye Girl is one I like. And the Blake Edwards stuff. I mean, those big commercial films, I mean, someone's gotta write them, Tina. They don't write themselves.
布鲁克林。那尼尔·西蒙改编并成为像《加州套房》这样的电影呢？对，加州套房，还有《再见女郎》我也挺喜欢。还有布莱克·爱德华兹的作品。我的意思是，那些卖座的大商业片，总得有人写啊，蒂娜。它们可不会自己蹦出来。
Nobody goes to that shit. I don't think they mixed comedy films anymore. They make like- We put them on Netflix. Let's do that. Yeah. Oh no, man. I saw up some poll online today.
没人去看那种破玩意儿。我觉得现在没人拍喜剧电影了。他们拍那种——我们把它们放到奈飞上。就这样吧。好吧。噢不，伙计。我今天在网上看到一个投票。
It was like, if you could only live with three of these film franchises, which one would it be? And it was like Marvel, Star Wars, like Harry Potter, like all the, and I was like, wait, that's what it's become? That's it? Those are the films?
内容大概是，如果你只能选三个电影系列活下去，你会选哪个？里面有漫威、星球大战、哈利·波特，诸如此类的，然后我就想，等等，电影现在就变成这样了？就这？这就是那些电影？
Fuck that, man. Yeah. And nobody's funny. This is crazy. I can't wait for the letters and the comments. Oh, nobody's funny anymore. Yeah, okay. Yeah, you're hilarious.
去他的吧，伙计。对啊。而且没人有趣了。这太疯狂了。我都等不及看信件和评论了。哦，现在没人有趣了。好吧，行。对，你太滑稽了。
I love it. Bring it on. No, you're not saying that. You're saying that comedies are not in the theaters anymore, really. Yes, that's what I'm saying. Nobody's making comedy films. No one's gonna make the in-laws now.
我喜欢。放马过来。不，你不是那个意思。你的意思是喜剧现在真的不上院线了。对，这就是我的意思。没人拍喜剧电影了。现在没人会拍《岳父大人》了。
The original in-laws nobody's gonna make. No, nobody's making, you can't make Rushmore today. Nobody's making Rushmore. You'd make it for Netflix, I guess. But I'm fine watching it at home on my couch. I don't need to drive with theater to see that, right? I mean, I'd go to a theater to see some big, huge format, right, a big IMAX thing or something.
原版的《岳父大人》没人会拍了。对，没人拍了，你今天拍不出《青春年少》。没人拍《青春年少》。我想你会为奈飞拍吧。但我坐在家里沙发上看也挺好的。我不需要开车去电影院看那个，对吧？我的意思是，我会为了某种宏大、超大格式的画面去电影院，比如看个巨大的IMAX什么的。
You come ask them. Is that Penelope? Come ask them, what's your question? How much longer? Okay, we're almost done. Sorry, we're almost done. We're wrapping up now, we're gonna wrap it up. Your agent looks real young.
你来问她们。那是佩内洛普吗？来问问她们，你的问题是什么？还要多久？好吧，我们快搞定了。抱歉，我们快搞定了。我们现在要收尾了，马上就收尾。你的经纪人看起来真年轻。
Yeah, we are past our hour here. I know, we've been taking up way too much of your time. I'm sorry that we're keeping you from the fact, because I wanna keep you on, I just want your opinion on everything, I feel like anytime I get your opinion, it feels like it's really the right one. Yeah, for sure. So that's why we've been keeping you around.
对，我们这里已经超时了。我知道，我们占用了你太多时间。很抱歉打扰了你的现实生活，因为我想留住你，我只是想要你对所有事的看法，我觉得每次听到你的看法，都觉得那是真正正确的。是的，绝对的。所以这就是我们一直留着你的原因。
But- Opinions are all I have anymore, go. No, it's so good, you've got. We're gonna dismiss you, but we're gonna reserve the right to call you back with any questions we have. That's right. Anytime, guys. Oh, you're the best.
但是——意见就是我仅剩的全部了，说吧。不，这太棒了，你拥有。我们要让你下线了，但我们保留随时打电话向你请教问题的权利。没错。随时，伙计们。哦，你们太棒了。
Thank you so much for taking your time to do this. I love you, Tina Fey. Saturday, you're the best. I love all three of you. Love you, Tina. Go have fun with the rest of your day with that sweet girl. Girl, yeah.
非常感谢你花时间做这些。我爱你，蒂娜·菲。周六，你最棒了。我爱你们三个。爱你，蒂娜。去和那个可爱的女孩享受剩下的时光吧。女孩，对。
Hey! Okay, we love you. Go be a boy, mom. All right, guys. Love you, Tina. I love you. Thank you. Thanks, Tina.
嘿！好啦，我们爱你。去当个男孩的妈妈吧。好啦，伙计们。爱你，蒂娜。我爱你。谢谢。谢谢，蒂娜。
Bye, everybody. Boy, just another- She wanted to get off there at the end. Yeah, do you think she gave a cue to Penelope to come in and say, okay, now this is the time where I need you to- No, she had it now. No, she's- Everybody knows who she is.
再见，各位。天哪，又是一个——她最后想挂断了。对，你觉得她是不是给佩内洛普使了个眼色，让她进来假装说，好吧，现在是我需要你——不，她现在搞定了。不，她——每个人都知道她是谁。
Everybody knows how brilliant she is. Everybody knows, everybody's a fan. It seems like that's the one person everybody can agree on, right? That's, oh my God, she's- I would like to find the person that doesn't like Tina Fey. Like who, yeah, who's that person?
每个人都知道她有多才华横溢。每个人都知道，每个人都是粉丝。感觉这就是唯一一个所有人都能达成一致的人，对吧？那就是，哦天哪，她是——我想找出那个不喜欢蒂娜·菲的人。比如谁，对，谁是那种人？
How could you possibly not? Yeah. I know she's the most, she's just so frickin' funny. She's such an unbelievable writer and a great joke writer. I mean, just the funniest. Doesn't take herself or anything too seriously. Always has the funniest joke on everything.
你怎么可能不喜欢？对。我知道她是那种最棒的人，她就是那么搞笑。她是一个如此难以置信的编剧，也是个伟大的笑话写手。我的意思是，简直是最好笑的。对自己或任何事都不太严肃。对每件事总能抖出最好笑的包袱。
It's scary. It's intimidating. Yeah, she's- It must be for someone, you know, for you guys. A great leader seems like a great leader. Incredible leader. Yeah, I'm very drawn to her. It was great.
这太可怕了。很有压迫感。是的，她是——对某些人来说一定是的，你知道，对你们来说。一个伟大的领袖，看起来像个伟大的领袖。不可思议的领袖。是的，我很被她吸引。这太棒了。
I mean, you were on 30 Rock a few times or once? Just once, the finale of that first season. Just once. Will, you were on it a bunch of times, weren't you? I guess. Well, that's what the four Emmy nominations tell me. But, you know- Wait, what?
我的意思是，你上过好几次《我为喜剧狂》还是就一次？就一次，第一季的大结局。就一次。威尔，你上过好多次吧？我猜吧。好吧，四次艾美奖提名就是这么告诉我的。但是，等等——什么？
Come on. I mean, it doesn't matter. Oh. It doesn't matter. Wait a second. Is that true? Is that true? Honestly, were you on for four seasons?
拜托。我的意思是，这不重要。哦。这不重要。等一下。这是真的吗？这是真的吗？老实说，你演了四季？
Yes. But did you get nominated? Four times, yeah, yeah. Congratulations. Congratulations. Yeah, four. Congratulations. Wait, so guess, so you did four episodes.
对。但你被提名了吗？四次，对，对。恭喜。恭喜。对，四次。恭喜。等等，所以猜一下，你拍了四集。
You got nominated for all four. No, I did more than four episodes. I did a bunch. I did, like, the first season I did one or two. It was not their first season. It was like- So do you want me to do an impression of your mom really quick? Yeah, go ahead.
你四集都获得了提名。不，我拍的不止四集。我拍了很多。我拍了，比如第一季我拍了一两集。那可不是它们的第一季。那是——所以你想让我快速模仿一下你妈吗？对，来吧。
Yeah. Well, it would have been more impressive if you won. That's true. That's very true. Should be much more impressive if I had won. Yeah. Oh, God, I- She's listening.
好吧。如果你赢了的话，会更有说服力。确实如此。千真万确。如果我赢了的话，应该更有说服力。对。哦，天哪，我——她在听。
We can cut that if you- No, we can keep it. You know, the first time, Jason, you know this story. We were coming back, the rest of the development had won the Emmy for best comedy. And 2004, whatever that was. And the next day, that was a Sunday night. The next Monday, we had to be at work early.
如果你想的话，我们可以剪掉——不，我们可以留着。你知道的，第一次，杰森，你知道这个故事。我们当时在往回赶，剧组的其他成员凭借《发展受阻》赢得了最佳喜剧艾美奖。那是2004年，随便哪一年吧。第二天，那是星期天晚上。接下来的星期一，我们得一早就去上班。
You and I were in that scene. Do you remember we had the Emmy? Those guys, Chuck Martin, brought his on set. We were so excited that we won. Improbably, because we were such a low-rated show. And I'm driving to the Fox lot from Venice and my mom calls. And it was like 6 a.m. L.A. time.
你和我都演了那场戏。你还记得我们带着艾美奖吗？那些家伙，查克·马丁，把他的奖杯带到了片场。我们太兴奋了，居然拿了奖。这简直不可思议，因为我们是一部收视率很低的剧。我正开着车从威尼斯区去福克斯片场，我妈打来电话。那时洛杉矶时间早上6点左右。
And I've been up until three, because we were so excited. I was like, oh my God, did you watch- Did you see the Emmys last night? No, we won. I did. Now, your sister is going through, and then just complete. Oh.
我一直熬到三点，因为我们太兴奋了。我说，哦天哪，你看——你看了昨晚的艾美奖吗？不，我们赢了。我看了。然后，你妹妹正在经历，然后彻底。哦。
Oh. I was like, okay. It was a very sort of Canadian. Like, the whole idea is always like, don't get too big for yourself. Right. You know, and don't like, oh, you think that you're better than anybody else?
哦。我当时想，好吧。这是一种非常加拿大式的反应。就像，整个理念总是：别太把自己当回事。对。你知道的，别觉得——哦，你觉得自己比别人都优越？
Like, I guess I don't. I'm sorry, I don't. I think I'm worse. And I'm like, there we go. That's more like it. You know, the idea, have you ever heard the story about the two lobster fishermen, one Canadian, one American, or walking down the road?
就像，我想我没有。对不起，我没有。我觉得自己更糟。然后我就想，这就对了。这还差不多。你知道那个概念吗，你听过那个关于两个龙虾渔夫的故事吗，一个加拿大人，一个美国人，在路上走着？
And the American lobster fisherman says to the Canadian, he says, notice that you don't have a lid on your lobster pot thereby. Aren't you worried that your lobster is going to get out? And the Canadian says, no, these are Canadian lobsters. If one of them tries to get out, the other ones will pull them back down. Sheesh.
美国龙虾渔夫对加拿大渔夫说，他注意到你的龙虾篓上没有盖子。难道你不担心你的龙虾会爬出来吗？加拿大人说，不，这些是加拿大的龙虾。如果其中一只想爬出来，其他的会把它拽回去。天哪。
That's Canada. Oh, Lord. That's Canada. That's what I grew up in. Oh, bless. And I love Canada. I love it to death. And I grew up like that too.
这就是加拿大。哦，天哪。这就是加拿大。这就是我长大的环境。哦，天呐。我爱加拿大。我爱死它了。我长大也是这样的。
It's a very, there's a very sort of, anyway, I don't know why I love this. Speaking of Canada, have you given any thoughts? I don't imagine you're going to book the guest for our Toronto stop for our tour, our tour. Which, listener, it does look like it's firming up. It does look like we're going to actually do this and we're going to go to a few cities.
这是一种非常，总之，我不知道我为什么喜欢这个。说到加拿大，你有什么想法吗？我猜你不会去给我们巡演的11月多伦多站预订嘉宾吧。听众朋友们，看起来这件事正在敲定。看起来我们真的要这么做了，我们要去几个城市。
Just inside the new year. Just inside the new year. 2022. And we're starting the tour in Toronto. Is that right, eh? We can say that, yeah. And then some New York and some Boston, some Chicago, some Madison, some LA, is that right?
就在新年伊始。就在新年伊始。2022年。我们将在多伦多开启巡演。是这样吗，哈？我们可以这么说，对。然后是一些纽约站、波士顿站、芝加哥站、麦迪逊站、洛杉矶站，是这样吗？
I think that's right, yeah. So who would we, can we, will you try to? I have a couple people in mind that I want to have for Toronto, you know. I know that's Chicago. We should start taking suggestions for guests. Yeah, we should. That's a good idea.
我想是的，没错。那我们会是谁，我们可以，你会去试着吗？我心里有几个人选想请到多伦多，你知道的。我知道那是芝加哥。我们应该开始接受嘉宾建议了。对，我们应该。这是个好主意。
Just saying the expression tap link in bio, does that mean anything? Tap link in bio. What does that mean? Who's link in bio? That's what you say on like Instagram, you know. Tap link in your bio. Tap link in bio.
刚才说到“点击简介里的链接”这个词，它有什么含义吗？点击简介链接。那是什么意思？谁的简介链接？那是你在Instagram上会说的话，你知道的。点击你简介里的链接。点击简介链接。
You know what else they say sometimes on Instagram, but more on that. Don't you do it, not yet. We're still talking. We're still talking. Jesus fucking Christ. Are you all right? He gets so excited when he figures that up high.
你知道他们有时在Instagram上还说什么吗，不过细节以后再说。别介，还不行。我们还在聊天。我们还在聊天。他妈的耶稣基督。你没事吧？他一想到那个高潮就激动成这样。
It would have been perfect. I know it would have been perfect, but we need, we have a few more things that we need to do about the tour to talk. Okay. Because the tour is becoming a reality. Yes. Sean, do you have a person in mind for Chicago?
本来会很完美的。我知道这本会很完美，但我们需要，我们还有一些关于巡演的事情需要讨论。好吧。因为巡演正在变成现实。对。肖恩，你对芝加哥站有合适的人选吗？
I do, I have several, but I don't want to say them out loud. Yeah, don't say them out loud yet. Yeah, how are we going to decide who's booking what cities? Well, why don't we, well. Well, here we have to do dibs. And I want to do dibs, you ready? Toronto and Wisconsin.
我有，我有几个，但我不想大声说出来。对，先别大声说出来。对，我们要怎么决定谁来订哪个城市呢？嗯，为什么我们不，嗯。好吧，这里我们得先“占位”。我想先“占位”，准备好了吗？多伦多和威斯康星。
Oh, you want Madison. You're going to take me. I want Madison. Even though it's my sister. Wait, but are we going to Madison strictly to see Sean's niece, nephew? My sister. And your sister.
哦，你想要麦迪逊。你要带上我。我想要麦迪逊。尽管那是我妹妹。等等，但我们去麦迪逊难道纯粹是为了见肖恩的侄女、外甥吗？我妹妹。还有你妹妹。
Your sister. Fucking idiot. And how could Tracy be his nephew, man? I guess it could be. I've met a couple of Tracy dudes. Yeah, I do too. I have too. But all these guests need to be sort of germane
你妹妹。他妈的笨蛋。特雷西怎么可能是他侄子呢，老兄？我猜也有可能。我见过几个叫特雷西的家伙。对，我也见过。我也有。但所有这些嘉宾都得和地点有点关系。
to the location. Yes. That's right, that's right. So the idea is we're going to have guests who are germane, hopefully like a very sort of organic, not shoehorned in pick. So think about it. I think that what we got to do is though,
有关联。没错，没错。所以我们的想法是，我们要请那些有地理渊源的嘉宾，最好是一种非常自然、而不是硬塞进来的选择。所以考虑一下。我觉得我们要做的其实是，
we got to make sure. Here it comes. Nice. Why? You want a bite? I can't, but for the tour though, if you want to talk about the tour. No, I'm not saying that there's rules.
我们必须确保。它来了。太棒了。为什么？你想来一口？我不能，不过为了巡演的事，如果你想谈巡演的话。不，我不是说这里有什么规矩。
I'm not saying that there are rules to this. I'm just saying that you have to check the. Bite us. So bad. Okay, goodbye. Bye. Bye. Smart.
我不是说这有什么规矩。我只是说你得检查一下。咬我们吧。太糟了。好吧，再见。再见。再见。真聪明。
Nice. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不错。聪明。聪明。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。